le colon dit très clairement il est
interdit aux musulmans des nouer des
relations d équité et d bienfaisance
avec les juifs ou les chrétiens qui nous
qui vous ont pas combattus et qui venez
vous ont pas sorti des dévots de marc
malgré la compréhension littérale que sa
fin pour avoir du coran ce qui se
passait dans l'action c'est est ce qu'on
peut appeler axe islamique comme le pacs
commando c'est à dire un homme qui
étaient là qui était pas parfait
maîtrise c'est à faire progresser les
choses on a le droit de manger chez les
chrétiens les juifs on a le droit de se
marier avec l'internât riaj contre
musulmans et juifs et chrétiens c'est
permis manger chez eux c'est permis ces
visites et se permit même les prophètes
avaient des très bonnes relations
d'harmonie toute sa vie avec les gens ce
qu'on appelle en prend les gens du livre
ça veut dire les chrétiens et les juifs
qui est nalcor 1
ça peut se prêter souvent 506 beaucoup
sur la paix en trombe alors qu'encore en
dit parfois semblent le dire une chose
et son contraire mais ça dépend des
circonstances
ça dépend à qui on s'adresse et la
question qu'il faut se poser c'est
pourquoi certaines personnes choisissent
de ne retenir que ce qui est violent
aujourd'hui on peut pas vivre au 21ème
siècle à l'islam qui n'a pas été révisée
ou mises à jour depuis siècle c'est pour
ça ça donne à toutes sortes de de
barbarie de dijon 2-2 confisqués ou de
prétendre parler au nom de l'islam et
des musulmans